hi I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to be talking about uh
continuation in our timy waza series I'm
going to give you a uh few little drills
that I use and transitions from one into
the next and the next we're going to
talk about ski yokan and showman and
gaku yokan also in this and I'll kind of
give you some ways you can work with
those again this is on the receiving
side of the attim and not the giving
side of the atimi and I know that kind
of is important for people people really
into the giving side of a Timmy but uh
we're going to do a couple more
clarifications with the receiving side
I'm going to get Josh out here we're
going to go to work
Josh all right so let's continue our
atimi waza series last time we talked
about the yokan position the showman
position how they were different um so
today I'm going to talk kind of about
some little drills you can do that will
vastly improve your ability to receive
iido a timi um I'm actually going to
make one more video that I think the
whole picture kind of puts it together
for you and it's a little bit easier to
understand um so uh understand that Josh
has three regular strikes he's going to
use in iido so he's either going to use
a uh can you switch yeah yeah okay so
he's either going to use a
ski he's going to use a showman F or
he's going to use a yokan f the next
video we'll talk about why those steps
that he's taking are important they
might seem silly to you um but we'll
talk about those steps in the next video
but those are the basic three so those
are the three I need to kind of train
for okay now I can make little nice
drills for each one of those to go
through them so let's say Josh skis and
I do our basic suto moari if Josh comes
around right now switches knife hand he
is now on the other side to come in and
thrust so he can thrust again I can Sil
the moari he can come around switch Sil
the Moi so you can get your students
used to as they move around practicing
your Sil thei over and over over right
I'll try and force us back here where
we're supposed to be there we go it's
okay all right so you can see that we
can make a little back and forth drill
with the ski for that right okay we can
do the same thing with yokom manucci
right so let's say uh Josh is coming in
with a yokan as he comes in here I blend
with it now Josh comes through trades
off to the other side and now he's ready
for yokan on the other side and come
through switches off boom boom boom boom
right so I can practice those over and
over and over and over and over and I
can do those with the uh the Gom barai
the low pass the jod on barai the high
pass right and so let's say we're up
high okay and I want to do a high pass I
can do this now Josh can switch hands
come around boom here I can high pass
bang Josh can come by okay I can do it
with low pass right like I just did a
second ago here fom sweep by Josh comes
around boom there it is right and so we
can high pass low pass back and forth so
that way he can practice those I can do
the same thing with showman and uh um
yaku yokuman because they end up in the
same position right which is here okay
now this one's a little bit trickier
because of the way the hand orientation
will go um and I don't want to
transition to like this like I do for
the the yokan or whatever so what I'll
do is I'll start to go eating me and
Josh will just switch hands and there it
it'll be right there boom and there it's
coming up right and so this is me going
to the backside him switching hands and
coming across and I'll do it so you can
see Josh too right so I'm here as I
transition here he switches hands right
in front and he comes up there boom and
there it is right there right okay so we
can make a drill with each one of those
individually and that gives your
students lots of reps practicing their
basic defenses for them then we can
stack those together so we give a little
spontaneous practice for them right so
if we're here like this and Josh comes
in boom there's our initial blend I do a
low pass Josh is switching hands he
comes in ski I turn suto moari he comes
in oh there's a showman so I come here
I'm transitioning back oh there's a
showman again right I so he comes oh he
switched hands on me he comes in ski oh
there's a yokan I'm doing High past that
time right so I can practice all of my
transitions uh with all the different
attacks coming off however they come off
right so um this will give your students
a little more comfortability in
switching between the different strikes
right and so then that means you can
avoid the terrible iido stuff that we're
going to talk about in the next video
which is uh this one right where they go
they go I'm coming to get you in Gaza
right and this this thing you know or uh
I'm coming with ski bro I'm coming with
ski bro right and we're going to talk
about why those are are silly in the
next video video but you can see here we
can give a little practice for your
students to practice the basic defenses
against those of Timmy over and over and
over with Transitions and doing
different options which makes it really
good so I hope that helps the next
series we're going to talk about that
stepping distance in awai it's important
and how to avoid the I'm coming for you
bro um we'll talk about that in the next
video I'm Christopher H this is Joshua T
myON danels behind that camera right
there
n
[Music]